one of the reassuring things that we are seeing
lately is that no matter what Donald Trump does,
Joe Biden is steadily moving forward with a
steady hand. He's having meetings. He has his
own coronavirus task force. He's choosing cabinet
members, including secretary of state, who we
talked about earlier, Anthony Blinken. And this
is so triggering to Donald Trump, it's very clear
that Donald Trump is trying to pretend this isn't
going on. He's golfing all weekend. He's otherwise
not leaving the White House. He's sort of been
sucked into this world of his sycophants and yes,
men. But this really seemed to boil over during
the weekend as Donald Trump unleashed a completely
unhinged tweet storm. And this is really the
stuff of history books. We have never seen
a sitting president react this way just to losing.
That's all that happened. He just lost. It's
nothing more. It's nothing less. Donald Trump
tweeting, Why is Joe Biden so quickly forming
a cabinet when my investigators have found
hundreds of thousands of fraudulent votes
enough to flip at least four states, which in
turn is more than enough to win the election?
Hopefully the courts or legislatures will have
the courage to do what has to be done to maintain
the integrity of our elections and the United
States of America itself. The world is watching.
Joe Biden is forming a cabinet because he won. Joe
Biden's not even doing it particularly quickly.
It's that Donald Trump is slow to acknowledge
that he lost. There are not enough votes to
flip a single state that we are aware of at
this point in time. Never mind four states.
The world is laughing at Trump and crying at
the downfall of American democracy in terms of a
sitting president attacking the democratic process
in this way. And the world is also rejoicing that
Donald Trump will be leaving. Trump then continued
tweeting, quote, It's all about the signatures on
the envelopes. Why are the Democrats fighting so
hard to find them? We will find a massive numbers
of fraudulent ballots. The signatures won't match.
Fight hard. Republicans don't let them destroy
the evidence. Every single one of these tweets
flagged by Twitter as disputed, which, you know,
as I said last week disputed, is like the
understatement of the decade at this point.
And then Trump furious. Apparently, he thinks
he deserves credit for the upcoming vaccines
and that Biden will get the credit. Trump
saying they never thought a vaccine could be
done so soon. But don't worry, they will try
to give the credit to Biden. Now, of course,
everyone thought that given these
MRSA vaccine platforms, which are
faster to develop, that the vaccine would be
done sometime around the end of the year 2020.
That is exactly what it seems like it will be and
that they will start to be more widely available
in the first quarter of twenty, twenty one. So
everybody everybody thought that if you were
paying attention and then just Trump attacking
Joe Biden more tweeting Joe Biden was a total
disaster and handling the H1N1 swine flu would
never have produced a vaccine in record time,
years ahead of schedule. I mean, everything about
that is a lie and would do a terrible job of
vaccine delivery. But doesn't everyone already
know that this went on all weekend in and out
of golfing, Trump was tweeting agit trash about
Joe Biden. It has to end. Joe Biden's forming a
cabinet because that's what the president elect
does during the ten weeks between Election Day
and Inauguration Day. Courts are dismissing Donald
Trump's lawsuits because they are without merit.
States aren't flipping because Biden won
the states. You know that phrase threats,
foreign and domestic, this unwillingness to accept
the loss and continued attempts to subvert the
will of the people. This is one of those domestic
threats that we are so often warned about. We have
to protect against it. And so far and I know we
have to be cautious, but realistic so far, every
attempt that they have had to subvert the will of
the people has not worked. I don't believe it will
work. And I think we are just under two months
from the inauguration of President Joe Biden.
Full stop.
If you think the outcome will be something else,
let me know. I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.